hey what's going on guys I'm Joey from
collider games and I'm Chloe from
clatter heroes and we are here with this
gorgeous ps4 pro here today this is this
is your own personal spider-man ps4 pro
i pre-ordered this the moment I could I
got it in the first three minutes I
think it was from dropping i pre-ordered
it while I was at comic-con and I
haven't gained since ps2 so this is
quite the leap it's the most expensive
single game of my life hopefully it
changes me into a gamer but as of now
this is a 400 game and I'm very happy to
spend I think you're in for a treat this
is a one terabyte ps4 pro exclusive for
spider-man so let's take this box apart
but before we do the box itself the box
itself is gorgeous you want to flip it
around and show everyone the art so I
walked into an undisclosed store and I
saw a stack of this waiting for me and I
was struck it was staggering I'm in love
look at that I mean that artwork this
this is a more detail than I've seen on
any box ever and you know like even just
like the little things like the Daily
Bugle worth noting you've got a bugle ad
here we've got a New York City pizza ad
here you've got like tons of Easter eggs
to what I assume is parts of the games I
haven't played it yet but the amount of
layering and the people this is a New
York subway and they look like New
Yorkers that's beautiful yeah so we want
to we want to open up the box we want to
take a look at what's inside do it let's
give credit to the color of the box
which I appreciate oh yeah amazing red
all right let's do this thing
so apparently this is the first time
they've ever released a red ps4 they're
talking about that at the at Comic Con
so I'm actually gonna mount it under my
TV and have this out facing so this will
be a part of oh yeah yeah so you get the
web yeah the logo alright let's take a
look at what we got here oh that's
pretty
there we go
tonight it's nice and it's nice and safe
it's it's good I appreciate this side up
thank you and what spider-man console
would be complete without a copy of the
game this is perfect
oho look at the gloss on that that's
beautiful look at this like that you've
got the glossy part here if you take a
look at this
yeah untouched it and I'm Maris like we
should be handling this with gloves yeah
are there
CSI gloves because yes but so you've got
the glossy front piece the the kind of
chromed logo there the matte spider but
then also yes so the spider itself is
matte but then also this part of the red
is Matt too so it gives it this great
pop it almost has that comic flavor of
like an inker versus the actual colors
in the panel to go super geeky but yeah
that would be that's that's the visual
I'm getting plus if you look at it very
aesthetically the black inlays opposite
the red of the spider-man gives it that
spider suit look which i think is plus
you're gonna I'm assuming when you power
it up you're gonna get the blue ps4 like
a swag action you get some snotty colors
a little leg action you got to show a
little leg Sony we appreciate yeah so
where where is art art please all the PS
force like where it's uh yeah yeah there
are little raked I think so when when
they went to the ps4 Pro they had this
three-tier rake and before that it was
like a two-tier thing and you you slot
the disc kind of in between the tiers
there there's gonna be a ten-hour window
of me just learning how to turn on a
Playstation oh yeah I get to play the
PlayStation welcome welcome to like the
era of like touch but you were like
downloads day one I was like oh the disc
doesn't have everything oh yeah that's
that's its own separate issue that we'll
get into but this is the other thing
this is what you're gonna be the most
associate look at her look at that it's
got the matte look of the the lower part
there I you know what I was not a fan of
the white buttons like originally I
wanted a little bit of like blue or
black yeah but I'm coming around to it I
think it really like
here yeah I'd love a line and blue like
maybe a blue here like something
personally but I don't mind this at all
yeah and I actually I play with like one
of the regular red controllers that came
from you know just when they're making
different colors and stuff so it's red
and black and I like having the red and
white now that I'm not I don't see I
like the subtle details and the overlay
there yeah and then you've got
everything about the buttons here if you
take a look that doesn't have like the
color edition it's all red to the to the
buttons there and gosh that's great and
then it comes with the normal stuff that
you would get with any console you get
an HDMI cable you get your power cable
you get a USB charging cable for the
controller itself and then you get the
tiniest of tiny headsets you're gonna
need this when you're playing online and
telling everyone how cool it is to swing
around and play spider-man I'll be
learning a lot at once and also learning
how to swing everything I've seen about
the swinging in the dynamics of that
look insane I've just I'm so glad I went
all the way with this what is it back
like like a red PlayStation logo and see
this like this is the cool thing about
this this I think this is the case on
all ps4 pros but even a little like
stands that lift it so that you get some
air underneath those are like those are
button logos that's the you know
triangle circle X square so you know
just the little details that they have
in this console and I like that the
front is is you know not matte the back
is matte and the young the the shininess
of the logo there this is such a pretty
console well guys this is the spider-man
limited edition ps4 pro go pick up one
yourself if you can go at least like go
into a store in oggela because this is
this is a pretty console and I'm happy
that you have one I'm gonna need to go
get one myself it was it was a impulse
choice at midnight and I'm so glad
months later this is in my life I don't
need a third ps4 in my house but I kind
of need or do useful or do you so thank
you so much Tony thank you for giving
spider-man all of the love he deserves
and thank you for making this because it
got me back into gaming single-handedly
I'm in this dokgo gaming in a decade I
haven't games since prior man so
well you know what if you're looking for
information on spider-man you can check
out Collider games for more spider-man
coverage and where can they find you
and if you're looking for information
about spider-man himself check out
Collider heroes where I am here in this
very Network and I love the character I
can't wait to find out what they've done
with them so excited until next time
keep on gaming
[Music]